this is what they're calling the
Sunshine State Search America is far
from out of the woods with coronavirus
in Miami it doesn't even look like it's
on the right path at the Convention
Center
it's mostly young people testing
positive and the governor says they're
partying is to blame people weren't
inside they were waiting to get outside
so I just felt like when everybody got
the actual chance to get out they would
rush out and not protect themselves
honestly you know you get messages from
the government we're nice then you get
messages from local government it's
optional I think it should be straight
across the board that everyone is
required to wear one right now because
we'll keep having these surges there are
now more than 145,000 cases in Florida
another 5,000 today alone the state
rushed to reopen now they're racing to
restrict this is a pretty stark
illustration of how dramatic this surge
is here in Miami on the left side we've
got a long line of cars I've been
waiting for hours and 35 degrees heat to
get tested for coronavirus and here lots
of people lining up to try and get a
free meal no matter what is said this is
a country very much still in the throes
of a pandemic outside the stadium where
he wants paid facebook Gaby Sanchez is
trying to help it is a pandemic it is
going on it hasn't stopped and you're
seeing it with these families who need
that help they need that food they need
the water to be able to just survive
maybe that extra week or two the beaches
full at the weekend looking sparse you
feel a bit vulnerable now oh yeah a
little bit but I think we've been doing
everything to stay safe so I'm not
really frightened but I am disappointed
he said like in the young people that
aren't taking it seriously it makes me
feel like that they're not considering
their effect on people my age
you know so yeah that makes me feel like
they're being a little selfish it's kind
of at the point that if you get it
you're gonna get it like there's so much
containing it they don't think there's
not much more than we can do unless you
go on total lockdown but I don't think
they're actually gonna do that on Friday
this will be closed to some seekers just
before Independence Day but will it be
enough or do units Tiny's Miami